beaucoup moins rigolo je préfère vous le
dire tout de suite on reçoit michel
sardou jean charles brisard
bonsoir bonsoir alors jean charles
brisard et expert international
spécialiste du terrorisme est chargé par
les parents de victimes du 11-septembre
de diriger l'enquète visant les réseaux
de soutien à al-qaïda et vous êtes
auteur c'est comme ça qu'on s'est connus
derrière avec guillaume dasquié de ben
laden la vérité interdite chez denoël
aujourd'hui vous publié chez fayard un
livre qui s'appelle zarqaoui le nouveau
visage d'al qaïda alors zarqaoui c'est
vrai qu'on entend parler à peu près à
chaque journal télévisé c'est le méchant
du moment où il est beaucoup plus de
méchants pour les gens encore que que
ben laden et c'est vrai qu'à dix jours
des élections en irak y mener le pays à
feu et à sang c'est la stratégie du
chaos
ils appellent au boycott des élections
évidemment alors vous raconter son
histoire d'abord il n'est pas
palestiniens contrairement à ce qu'avait
déclaré colleen powell au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu en 99
mais il est jordanien oui tout à fait ça
fait partie des nombreuses erreurs qui
ont été affirmés à cette époque par les
américains pour justifier en quelque
sorte la guerre il y avait l'origine
effectivement de deux heures car oui il
y avait également le fait qu'il
constitue en quelque sorte le chaînon
manquant entre al-qaïda et saddam
hussein et le régime de saddam hussein
ce qui n'a jamais pu être établie bon je
passe sur les nombreuses erreurs
factuelles qui ont été commises par les
américains pour encore une fois justifié
cette guerre ouais alors il est pas à
palestiniens les jordaniens il est né à
zarqa d'où son nom de zarqawi qui est
une ville deux camps palestiniens ou
depuis 50 ans les palestiniens qui sont
entassés là bas et c'est vrai que ça
crée des rancoeurs qui sont propices à
la politisation de l'islam quoi c'est un
vraiment à un creuset de huy lui à
l'islamisme lui a été éduqué
effectivement à proximité immédiate d'un
camp 50 palestiniens
il a eu une enfance face à un cimetière
ce qui explique dites-vous une certaine
fascination pour la mort il vit dans le
cimetière si vous voulez concrètement il
a il quitte l'école à
douze ans c'est quelqu'un qui errent
dans son cimetière qui a des jeux d
amusement autour de ces tombes
ces macabres bien sûr mais c'est sa vie
c'est là dedans témoigne toute son
enfance
c'est quelqu'un qui est une adolescence
de voyou un au départ il boit de
l'alcool il est tatoué il est tellement
de tatouages sur le corps qu'on
l'appelle l'homme vert il fait des vols
du trafic de drogue il est même impliqué
dans une histoire de viol
et c'est là que pour le remettre dans le
droit chemin
sa mère l'inscrit dans une mosquée
malheureusement une mosquée salafistes
très très très dur où il apprend le
jihad en fait oui là il
il est en contact concrètement et c'est
souvent le cas d'ailleurs dans la vie
d'un d'un combattant d'un combattants
arabes bungie qui va devenir un
djihadiste c'est qu'il ya une rencontre
forcément un mot un autre avec quelqu'un
qui devient un mentor un père spirituel
et c'est le cas du nommé mal tizi qu'il
va revoir par la suite en afghanistan et
qu'il va suivre et qu'il a su chan tout
suivre ces préceptes c'est à dire
finalement le jihad la guerre totale et
aujourd'hui le chaos
voilà donc qui part en afghanistan
s'entraîner dans des camps et au retour
il est arrêté il est mis en prison
pourquoi si vous voulez lorsqu'il
revient d'afghanistan il n'a qu'un souci
c'est de faire chez lui dans son pays
son son djihad c'est-à-dire de renverser
complètement la monarchie jordanienne
qu'il juge complice des américains etc
et puis ça va devenir un apprenti
terroriste en quelque sorte un pied
nickelé en a un et terrorisent parce
qu'il ne réussit pratiquement rien ou
alors il
il met en oeuvre des moyens qui sont
surdimensionnés par rapport à l'objectif
qu'il vise est effectivement il est il
est arrêté en 94 et détenu pendant cinq
années dans les geôles les geôles
jordanienne et c'est là qu'il va se
forger
7 cette violence d'abord réel et puis
cette cette âme de chef c'est là qu'il
devient véritablement un chef aux yeux
des autres mais grâce à la violence oui
mais en plus il n'hésite pas à raconter
qui s'est battu contre les soviétiques
en afghanistan alors qu'il est arrivé
après enfin il ya un mythe zarqaoui qui
se construit dans la prison il est
condamné à 15 ans de prison est en fait
il fera que quelques années parce qu'à
une pression des intégristes sur le roi
abdallah ii de jordanie et même on peut
dire du peuple jordanien quoi de
l'opinion publique jordanienne jordanien
à l'époque sont obligés de composer
malheureusement avec les islamistes ce
sont des gens magnifiques partie de ces
régimes qui sont très faibles au proche
orient et qui sont effectivement soumis
à une grosse pression de la part des
islamistes en particulier les frères
musulmans et le nouveau roi
effectivement cède à la pression des
islamistes comme c'est le cas dans comme
ça a été le cas dans notre pays d'un
coût de deux mondes d'al-qaïda qu'on
retrouve qui ont été emprisonnés et qui
ont malheureusement été libérés ce la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui la
jordanie si vous voulez et mal à l'aise
par rapport au phénomène zarqaoui alors
oui ça quant aux arts cas où il sort de
prison il s'adosse al qaïda est alors
lui il est une théorie sert que pour ben
laden
il y a bon les juifs et les croisés il
faut les combattre mais vous dites que
zarqaoui lui c'est pire que ça à dire
que tous ceux qui sont passés à la piste
sont des ennemis c'est à dire on peut
être hindouiste on est un ennemi quoi
j'ai relu c'est tout le monde tous ceux
qui ne sont pas qu'à fuir
oui parce que si vous voulez il a une
revanche lui apprendre son s'invite sur
la vie il est très complexe et des accès
même on peut dire
il a subi de nombreux échecs personnels
professionnels y compris sentimentaux sa
première femme sa deuxième femme on le
dit 13 ans c'est bien sûr qu'il ait un
problème ce garçon est pour lui
effectivement tout ce qui ne ressemble
pas à un sunnite salafistes
effectivement pur et dur c'est quelqu'un
qu'il faut combattre absolument et et
abattre
voilà alors en irak aujourd'hui il
fédère un peu tout les toutes les
organisations jihadistes oui parce qu'il
est celui qui encore une fois par sa
violence incarne le plus ce combat le
mieux ce combat contre les américains
c'est lui qui a des mourres qui dispose
de plus de moyens humains
c'est notamment lui qui fournit en
kamikaze d'autres groupes irakiens ne
s'adonnent pas ce type de pratiques
c'est lui qui fournit des moyens
financiers également faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui al-qaïda dépenses quatre
cinquième de son budget annuel 15
millions de dollars par an uniquement
pour l'irak
j'ai colossal pour cette résistance
entre guillemets et puis effectivement
on voit de plus en plus de groupes qui
sont des groupes tribaux et beaucoup de
groupes rivaux en irak aujourd'hui se
rallier à sa cause en particulier de
nombreux groupes conduit cette opération
désormais conjointe avec avec le groupe
demain car oui il fédère effectivement
et il incarne quelque chose plus mieux
que les autres
alors vous vous écrivez un bouquin sur
zarqaoui mais vous savez quand même que
pour certains groupes ultra gauche
zarqawi n'existe pas que c'est une
invention d america destinée à justifier
des opérations comme celle de falloudja
j'ai bien entendu ça oui j'ai rencontré
sa femme ses enfants son frère
il faut dire qu'il existe bien aider
réellement c'est pas un fantôme c'est
pas un fantôme de superman comme comme
on la lui intimant c'est pas une fiction
inventée par les américains pour
justifier la guerre d'irak
oui mais comment vous expliquez que
quand on aille sur le site des 21
terroristes les plus recherchés du monde
ww.carrefour.fr thuan terroristes
elle y soient pas et parce que si vous
voulez en irak enfin j'ai bien
conscience de cela d'ailleurs je relève
dans mon livre que interpol au moins de
novembre 2000
4 c'est à dire très récemment n'avaient
toujours pas émis de mandat d'arrêt
international contre lui en réalité il
est recherché en irak
zarqawi ce n'est pas considérée à cette
époque il récemment comme un terroriste
international
je pense qu'il le sera très
prochainement après l'adoubement qu'il a
reçu de sa ben laden ya très peu de
temps je crois qu'il a acquis une
stature qui désormais le place au même
rang quasiment quelques mois un bundle
pour vous c'est l'ennemi public numéro
un aujourd'hui c'est l'homme le plus
dangereux du monde
très clairement aujourd'hui oui parce
que c'est celui qui a repris en fessant
dans les faits en tout cas aujourd'hui
le flambeau du djihad et il est soutenu
il faut le savoir non seulement à
l'intérieur de l'irak mais également
dans les pays arabes des pays du golfe
des ong le soutiennent le financent des
groupes terroristes qui n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec l'irak il
ya moins d'une semaine le gspc algérien
les islamistes tchétchènes ont déclaré
soutenir zarqaoui et appelé de leurs
voeux lors de leurs propres combattants
à se rendre en irak se veut bien dire
qu'il fédère ce bien dire qu'il a pris
l'ascendant aujourd'hui sur ces
combattants question césar coly j'ai
peur des questions que je vais poser non
mais quels sont ses projets toi et rien
dans la question déjà je flippe madrid
il est impliqué indirectement un oui
voilà ses adjoints qui met en contact
avec
les centrales non mais c'est vrai que
une chance qu'il faut dire quand même
c'est qu'en france on perçoit souvent ce
conflit comme très lointain une réalité
des coûts plus proche de nous qu'on ne
le croit des gens qui ont été arrêtés en
france un réseau terroriste menace
bendjillali en particulier à lyon ce
sont des gens qui sont entraînés en
géorgie dans des camps d'entraînement
contrôlée par par sahraoui et qu'ils
voulaient commettre en france il attrapa
chimiques et puis un certain nombre de
groupes irakiens
ça fait quel c'est très récent quelques
jours on fait les déclarations c'est les
gens qui sont proches des heures car oui
on fait des déclarations disant lavaur
aujourd'hui on a mené le combat contre
les américains en irak
on a obtenu quelques succès il est temps
maintenant d'exporter ce conflit au
coeur même de l'occident
ça veut bien dire que le danger qu'on
croit lointain que la france pour
lointain réalité beaucoup plus proche de
vous pensez sérieusement c'est votre
boulot vous pensez jean-charles que nous
on se rend pas du tout content de ce qui
nous menace aujourd'hui il en est un peu
comme comme les juge pas les français en
39 par exemple avant là c'est parce que
je dis mais je constate qu'effectivement
la france dans ce domaine là une
politique qui est qui est extrêmement
ambiguë je veux dire par là quand on
travaille sur le terrorisme
quotidiennement comme je le fais on se
rend bien compte que ça ne suffit pas
une si pas de lutter contre les groupes
terroristes commun et qu'on peut
identifier qui sont facilement
identifiables d'ailleurs l'essentiel
c'est je crois de lutter contre ce qui
sous tend ces groupes terroristes dans
la la religion qu'il a son temps puisque
ces groupes vous savez al-qaïda et on
cite dans notre liste des documents
historiques d'al-qaïda des verbatim des
gens de la constitution de d'al qaïda
ben laden dit al qaïda est là pour
perpétuer l'esprit du jihad
c'est à dire concrètement sans le jihad
ces groupes n'existent pas il faut
lutter je crois non seulement contre les
groupes terroristes mais également
contre une idéologie radicale
le salafisme purs et durs effectivement
voulait dit que l'enfant au moment de la
discussion pour la libération de chesnot
et malbrunot est français on dit des
trucs absolument insensé que même si on
veut libérer deux otages
fa c'est ce qui ressort de votre bouquin
on peut pas dire des choses comme ça
vous voulez jamais à ma connaissance en
tout cas la doctrine jusqu'à présent
c'était pas qu'on pouvait discuter avec
des terroristes
ouais on est d'accord alors que qu'est
ce qu'on a vu concrètement monsieur
barnier aller serrer la main par exemple
un religieux qui s'appelle youssef al
qaradawi voilà que que lui-même a
qualifié de plus grande conscience de
l'islam youssef al qaradawi c'est lui
qui a justifié dans les attentats du 11
septembre
c'est lui qui
aujourd'hui lancent des fatwas pour
autoriser en irak a tué des non
seulement des militaires mais également
des civils
alors sans limite il y précise que
serait la mutilation montrent encore une
fois la même pour libérer deux otages
barnier peut pas dire de ce gala que
c'est une grande confiance de l'islam si
vous trouvez que finalement l'aide il me
semble oui lorsque le cfcm je le raconte
dans un livre aussi lorsque le cfcm
conseil français du culte musulman
seront délégation à bagdad au même
moment le chef religieux du sinus du
cfcm signe en catimini en quelque sorte
dans la presse arabe publié à londres
un texte appelant à soutenir par tous
les moyens moraux matériels l'honorable
résistance irakienne
oui oui il ya un double discours là je
sens que vous voyez c'est zéro
politiquement on est on est au coeur du
problème pour avoir pour laquelle j'ai
vu que la france est en quelque sorte
piégée par ces islamistes pour en finir
vous pensez que l'attitude de boucher
mieux que l'attitude du gouvernement
français
pas du tout bush est soumis également à
d'autres pressions d'autres formes de
pression dans la guerre contre le
terrorisme dont on l'a bien vu gelé
souligné dans le précédent ouvrage le
pressions politiques pressions
économiques à l'égard notamment de
l'arabie saoudite quand deux pays qui
ont pu soutenir financièrement marne
oralement ou idéologiquement al qaïda
mais les mêmes les mêmes problèmes se
posent aux états unis juliette une
charge ici question pour jean chanson -
en fait moi j'ai un côté très hachée
très rêveuse et je me dis que le
terrorisme est sans doute le symptôme
d'une maladie qu'il faudrait peut-être
envisager de soigner celle ci avait
aucune raison que ces gens soient
terroriste peut-être créé plus de
terroristes
si on arrête zarqawi et oussama ben
laden
il y en aura d'autres pour prendre la
relève caisse et l'inférence là jean
charles
je suis désolé partir c'est parti à fait
partie avec ça à faire mais à sigean
jacques